[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته يستسلم الكثير منا عندما يقف ويقع
ولا يك
المحاوله والمقصود من ذلك انك اذا خطوت
الخطوه قد تقع ثم
تنهض ثم تقع ثم تنهض ثم تقع مره اخرى ثم
تنهض لتكمل في مسارات
الحياه وذلك خير لك من ان تراوح
مكانك خير لك من ان محلك تسير وتقع في خ
الروتين وتمارس ذلك النشاط اليومي اللي
تطحن فيه جهدك ونفسك
وطاقتك مثلك مثل الرحه اللي تدور
وتدور وتدور ولكن بدون حب لا وتنادي وتكرر
انا المنجز انا
الفعال دون نتائج
تذكر هنا تنطبق على
مقوله نسمع جعجعه ولا نرى طحنا وانا شخصيا
ارفض ان اسمع جعجع تي دون ان يرى
طحني لذلك اجد اننا في هذه الحياه نعيش
ثلاث
حيوات الحياه الاولى هي الحياه
السهله والثانيه هي الحياه المتحديه
والثالثه هي الحياه
الكارثيه الحياه السهله هي الحياه التي
ننام فيها ونستيقظ
وننتظر الوقت والفرصه المناسبه متى ما
جاءت اما الحياه المتحديه هي الحياه التي
تطرح وتقسمك وتضربك وتلقن دروسا واختبارات
ومجموعها تجارب
وخبرات اما الحياه الكارثيه هي تلك الحياه
التي لا نعرف
قيمتها الا عندما نخسرها
ككارثة كل هذه المشاعر واللحظات ردات
افعال لتغيير معين قد يكون هذا التغيير
تغيير شخصي على مستوى فقدان عزيز لا قدر
الله او على مستوى تغيير عام كتغيير وظيفه
تغيير بلد رسوب في ماده
مثلا فكيف اذا نواجه هذا
التغيير اسمحوا لي اشارككم بمجموعه من
المفاتيح هذه المفاتيح قائمه على جراه
ادبيه اول مفتاح
فيها مفتاح
القدوه والنموذج
الانساني الاقتداء
بنماذج ناجحه والحو حذوهم فيه من الامر
الطيب والايجابي والفعال على التكوين
الشخصي من منكم مثلي لديه قدوه في
حياته نعم
اكثرنا انا صناعه
امراه هذه المراه هي من ربتني وساهمت في
تاسيس
شخصيتي
امراه
عصاميه بنت نفسها بنفسها نسميها اخت
رجال كانت من اوائل السيدات التي عملنا في
قطاع البترول في الدوله وكان كانت من
اوائل السيدات التتي حصلنا على رخصه
السياقه القطريه وكانت من اوائل الدفعات
التي تخرجنا من جامعه قطر حياتها كلها
جراه ادبيه في جراه ادبيه الى ان
اكتسبتها في حشمتي التزام
الديني موروث العادات تقاليد مبادئ قيم
هويه
وطنيه هذا المفتاح
الاول المفتاح ثاني هو التدريب ثم التدريب
ثم التدريب
بالثلاثه تدريب من خلاله يثقل الشخصيه
وينمي المهارات ويساعد على التواصل بشكل
فعال ويمكن من الخوض في المناقشات والظهور
بهذا الحضور قلبا
وقالبا كانت عندي صديقه تدرس بني وهي
مراتي من منكم يتحدث الى مراته
مثلي نعم كانت المراه رفيقه دربي وما زالت
حقيقه على حسب المواقف ادربها ت دربني
وغال طها تغالطني تحاورني
حاورها ولماما قررت اظهر اول ظهور على
التلفزيون
كضيف تدربت مرارا وتكرارا امام المراه الى
ان اعطتني الضوء الاخضر ومن ذلك الوقت
تملكتني تلك الجراه
الادبيه المفتاح الثالث هو مفتاح المبادره
واغتنام
الفرس اذكروا في سنه من
السنوات سنه تقريبا
2003 كنت اشاهد برنامج
تلفزيوني يستضيف مجموعه من الضيوف خارج
وداخل ووله كانت في تلك في ذلك الوقت كانت
ضيفه جذبتني صراحه
واعجبتني كانت حائزه على لقب ملكه جمال
الثقافه شاهدتها
باعجاب رفعت الهاتف لاحدث احدى ملهمات
واقول طيب ماذا ينقصني لاكون
مكانها ومنذ ذلك الوقت ومكانها نصب عينين
تدربت كثيرا ومرارا وتكرارا مع مراتي الى
ان وصلت وتواصلت مع المعنيين في البرنامج
بكل جراه ادبيه لاقدم نفسي شاعره قطريه
تكتب الشعر العربي والفصيح وكان لي
ذلك اما المفتاح الرابع هو مفتاح العلم
والمعرفه
والاطلاع التعلم
المستمر والاستفاده من العلوم
والمعارف يزيد
معدلات الانتاجيه وايضا يصقل الشخصيه
فكلما كنت على تخصص معين وايضا مخزونك
متنوع ولك من المعارف من كل قطر اغنيه
ستجد نفسك ذو منطوق سليم ومدعوم
فكريا اما بالنسبه للمفتاح الخامس وهو
شبكه
العلاقات جميل ان يربطنا بمعنا وغير
معارفنا علاقه تبادل لمصالح لخدمات معينه
بالمعروف على مبدا انت تفوز وانا افوز هنا
تتوسع العلاقات وال المشاركات ويتنوع ايضا
التواصل على مبدا ربع تعاونه
ماذلو
كل هذه
المفاتيح تحت مظله واحده الايمان بالله
واليقين بتحقيق الاهداف
والامور شخصيا مررت في مراحل التغيير
هذا وخصوصا عندما قررت ان اخرج من عالم
الشاشه ك مقدمه برامج وايضا من عالم
الوظيفه الحكوميه والدخول الى عالم رياده
الاعمال استجمعت كل هذه المفاتيح لاجدني
اليوم امامكم رائده اعمال متخصصه في قطاع
الاعمال الدبلوماسي سيده اعمال
واعلام على منصه تدكس جامعه قطر 20
23 تحت شعار احصان الامس تحسين الغد
وشكرا